the vision is to compete with a uh
nike or an adidas or under armour where
are you at now with the vision of jim
shark
listen i i think maybe i'm less about
scale
because if we want scale i think we
could get it
in terms of we could sell gym shark into
many high street stores and we could
double triple quadruple the business in
a very very quick time
frame for me it's about building what i
think the future of brands will be and
as i've mentioned before it's a
community-focused brand
that has you know you know a distinct
value behind it and i think
that's where i want to go so it's less
about scale but it's about creating the
best fitness brand in the world
and i think that comes with being a
direct to consumer brand a brand that is
agile and lean so we can invest into the
community and in the product rather than
in
you know thousands of shops around the
world so
we do we're doing incredibly well listen
we've we're eight years old
we're like i said half a billion dollars
in revenue we've been the uk's fastest
growing business from a top-line
perspective but we also had
we had won the award a couple of years
ago for the one of the uk's fastest
growing businesses from a profit
perspective as well
so many businesses scale the top line
but often not the bottom line
so for us to do both i think is really
powerful um
and it means that we can invest in the
long term of this brand in the long term
of this business and we're really
focused on those long term decisions
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye